لقد رأينا إلكًا عالقًا في إطار، وإيلًا
آخر محاصرًا في كرسي بار،
وسنجابًا ورأسه في كوب، وظربانًا
محشورًا في وعاء سكيبي، وغزالًا مغلفًا
في كيس دوريتوس أو يجب أن نقول
دوريتوس ولكن هذا خاص  الوصفة
خذ صينية واحدة لكعكة الطعام ناقص
المركز ثم ارفعها للخارج واخلطها في طفل صغير من
بنسلفانيا يبلغ من العمر عامين
وانسى الملعقة. هذه الوصفة لكارثة تستدعي
قواطع القصدير الصغيرة
كوينلي التي جعلت رأسها عالقًا في المقلاة التي كانت
ترتديها  مثل الشال حول
كتفيها حتى وصلت المزرعة إلى هناك،
اختار الجندي بسهولة، اختار بسرعة قدر
الإمكان، لم يكن هناك شيء سهل في
هذا الوضع غير المكتمل، الأم عالقة،
الأم عالقة، كوينلي، صرخت، اتصلت الأم برقم
9-1-1، كانت لا تزال لا تزال  كانت قادرة على الأكل
والشرب بينما كان لديها هذا القصدير حولها،
على عكس هذا الغزال وهذا الكلب،
كان الكلب مفترسًا عندما أخرجوا
الجرة البلاستيكية منها.
استخدمت شركة Junction Fire Company قصاصات القصدير لتقطيع
المقلاة في مكانين، كما تقول والدة كوينلي.
طفلة علقت ساقاها في
كرسي بلاستيكي، لذا ربما يكون موجودًا في
العائلة، قد لا تكون كوينلي ملاكًا ولكن
إنقاذها أخذ الكعكة، أدخلهما،
أخرجهما بسهولة، خبز رائع، جيني موس، سي إن إن
نيويورك واو